[Music]
[Music]
you
no dick is going to bring me into the
adventure today
we're starting in this car and then
going up in his Jeep his russian-made
Jeep to go high up into the mountains no
tech had been told his uh Loki told me
an excellent driver and gonna bring us
into some cool landscapes here outside
of catechol Turkestan and in this part
of the world they're very they're all
about the the process the experience so
you know we weren't far in but we
stopped at a restaurant coffee that from
my experience so far in Kyrgyzstan to
eat massive portions a lot of food I
already had porridge three eggs this
morning and notic no ducks ready to fuel
up so let's check out this scene here
another
nice neck
English now you see but not yet though
sometimes some sad okay it's meat meat
in onions and in a pastry it looks like
some chili pepper they're getting into
it and so the adventure started this
morning it's not knowing where I was
going
and then just going on the journey in
the journey just leads you to all these
new new experiences like this
[Music]
this is what a local store looks like
outside of ketika little tour here
watermelon they do they have amazing
melons russets it amazing melons in this
part of the world eggs like everywhere
in the world outside of I think the US
eggs are kept in the in the warmth
because in the u.s. they clean the shell
was some chemical I believe and then
they need to be refrigerated afterwards
but here they don't do that like most
places so eggs can just hang out in the
warmth they're pretty big on the sweets
here a lot of slot key lot of tea and
oil
I found out to be the truth oil
absolutely overused in my opinion use a
lot of oil in the food big on the energy
drinks and some beer and alcohol and
even though this is a Muslim place
the alcohols everywhere what's up yeah
yeah yeah they peel I don't drink
okay Snickers let's just say well what
you're gonna drink flash max who's now
she thinks it's delicious okay go go
stay still send 150 which is nearest 150
which is like $2 don't see Dania chase
leva bye bye good luck
and we got to a zone this place where
has his Jeep this is our machine no okay
yeah take it off
we're on a mission on an adventure up
somewhere into there yeah tried the work
and so then we took a we took over in
the Jeep
[Music]
so as we got up in altitude there's this
deep blue sky in this very vibrant green
and the trees and the wind rustling
through the leaves and the river raging
from snowmelt from glaciers we high open
the tea on Shawn's
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
rushon jeeps are made like tanks I mean
we just rallied over all that crazy
terrain and I swear to God if you run
out of gas you can put vodka in the tank
and if anything breaks you can use duct
tape so how - aw beautiful place this is
insane up here you guys it's some of the
most beautiful nature I've ever seen in
my life
gotta say you ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
horses some nomadic people you can see
there they're living off the land here
they've moved their yurts up for the
summer for their livestock to graze such
a raw special unique corner of the globe
the whole point of doing this is not
just to show off myself in beautiful
places it's really a I'd rather just put
the camera down for that and enjoy them
but my point of doing this is to show
you the viewer that well especially the
Western viewers so much of the world
we're told about to be dangerous is not
the case and there's been a lot of fear
baked into our education our news cycles
and yes do things happen in the world
for sure like there are places to avoid
I'm not stupid with this stuff I do my
research but are there many of these
places that we think to be dangerous
that aren't yes ton of them like here
like this Mountain Valley here in
Kyrgyzstan I'm gonna get out of the wind
here so those Peaks right back there
with the snow actually all the peaks
it's all part of the Tian Shan range
which go up to I think I think 7,000
meter ish maybe even more 7,500 meters
so in feet that's like what 23,000 ish
something like that massive massive
Peaks I feel very small I think it's the
most beautiful setting I've put my eyes
on in my life and I've seen a lot
I hope you can feel just a little bit of
that behind the screen it's worth coming
to though if you have the opportunity
it's worth coming it's worth breaking
out of the normal travel destinations
and going a little more adventuresome a
little more rugged if that's what you're
looking for if you're looking for that
life experience that is definitely one
of those places this is the language of
body language they speak a mix of keys
in Russian spasiba
so sniper comes up here mostly in the
winter in juice he shoots the wolves
in the winter they don't come down to
the valley the bear come in the valley
you're easy prey said Fox but the wolves
are the hard ones to snipe which improve
no wolf suba suba suba he makes coats
out of them so I thought he was selling
the whoops but now he's actually makes
coats out of the wolf hair
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the song again we heard this roughly
at times today
[Music]